well are you I kind of him are you
afraid of the dark took up a large part
of my childhood I love this show it was
sort of like the kids x-files every
single episode was a bunch of kids who
gather around a campfire at night and
tell each other ghost stories they're
known as the midnight society and every
single story they tell is then played
out for us and we get to watch them the
show was filmed in Canada right around
the same time goosebumps was filmed in
Canada and one of the things that's most
fun for me is it has also a fan of
goosebumps I noticed that the shows both
swap actors quite often in fact the
entirety of season 6 every single
episode of are you afraid of the dark
has an actor or actress that was in an
episode of goosebumps there are 7
seasons in total the first five seasons
all aired in succession one year at a
time and then there was a three year
hiatus in season 6 and 7 aired after
that the first five seasons are easily
the best in fact the finale of season 5
has a genuinely terrifying moment that
even as an adult I said to myself when
this scene happened oh I want to
show you something
you know I would think as an adult that
startled me but can you imagine being a
middle schooler and seeing that for the
first time I mean scarred for life as a
kid I love this show because of the
imagination every episode was different
it was always a different story about
something scary and since I love scary
stuff as a kid and I've grown up
continuing to love scary films and scary
TV shows as a kid this was one of my
favorite things to do it was big on
Nickelodeon back in the day I remember
they had marathons of it from time to
time sometimes it was on Saturday nights
snick block and you weren't in school
and it's time to get scared and it was
just so much fun the intro to this show
the intro still gives me chills I mean
just look at this
frickin clown man the show even inspired
a lot of Hollywood filmmakers M night
Shyamalan was heavily inspired by the
tale of the dream girl and he made the
sixth sense as a result the show
inspired me a lot as a kid and it
continues to inspire me today even
though when you go back and re-watch it
it's clearly dated we have to recognize
it was aimed at middle schoolers and if
I can watch it as an adult and still be
entertained even though there's
obviously some nostalgia there that's
not too bad after the hiatus season six
definitely tapered down in regards to
quality there's still a few good
episodes in there I like the last
episode of the season which by the way
stars Hayden Christensen who also was in
an episode of goosebumps as I said
season six of are you afraid of the dark
every episode has somebody from
goosebumps in it it's like the same
people made it or something or they knew
the casting agency or whatever they just
trade it off actors that's what
goosebumps on are you afraid of the dark
did but for me in elementary school and
through middle school watching are you
afraid of the dark felt almost like I
was sort of sneaking something my
parents maybe wouldn't have wanted me to
watch at the time it was like they were
okay with it they knew what it was it
was on Nickelodeon but when I watched it
I felt like I was just sort of sneaking
it by and I think for a lot of kids they
had a similar experience because it felt
like it was just maybe a little more
mature than everything else they were
used to and back then sometimes my
friends and I would build a fort or
something and read scary stories to each
other I don't know how much inspired by
are you afraid of the dark we were well
doing that but I know now thinking back
on those times that I definitely connect
those two events are you afraid of the
dark and reading scary stories
underneath a blanket fort
there's nothing better than that when
you're a kid there's nothing better than
sitting around with your friends and
scaring the Wits out of each other and
this show did that for us and it still
holds up mostly today some episodes are
not too good just like the goosebumps
show but I understand what the show was
going for and for that I appreciate it
did you guys have a favorite scary show
when you were a kid
there were a lot in the 90s it was
really popular largely because of the
x-files there were shows like so weird
on the Disney Channel Ghost Rider
bumps are you afraid of the dark there
were a lot of shows like that for me
when I was a kid what's your favorite
guys thank you so much for watching
another episode of retro rewind and if
you liked this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
submitted for the approval of the
midnight society I call this story the
tale of are you afraid of the dark retro
rewind that was a really long title